son más de 120 los mandatarios y líderes
ambientales que se reúnen para este
encuentro y pese que esa alta
participación puede considerarse
favorable se presenta una contradicción
y es que también hay mayores
posibilidades de división
así es buenos días
sí me parece que la cumbre ella marca
como en otras cumbres la división
primero en tres los países del norte y
los países del sur y en particular los
de latinoamérica y los de los países los
de zonas como áfrica pues están muy
atentos a las promesas que se han hecho
de dinero para apoyarlas los cambios
necesarios
mientras no exista este apoyo pues
difícilmente los países en desarrollo
con más necesidades con más pobreza van
a cumplir poder cumplir con sus promesas
hechas en las copas anteriores y ahora
en la que se quiere reafirmar en la top
26 me parece que la cumbre ya ha pasado
como ahora decían un poco amarga un
dulce amargo porque pues haya
mandatarios que no fueron y esto está
marcando ya alguna distancia sobre la
posible realización de las metas bueno
hay algo que llama la atención son los
plazos que suelen ponerse los líderes
que generalmente son de décadas a que se
debe por ejemplo establecer una meta a
2050 o a 2060 y no antes
pues me parece que es una costumbre de
dejar a otras las responsabilidades que
se deben de asumir ahora como los
reportes últimos de expertos paneles de
expertos han mostrado
tenemos ya muy pocos años de margen y si
no cumplimos las metas pues el
calentamiento que ya está aquí que ya no
es un algo por venir sino que está
presente se va a grabar sobre todo pues
ya vemos que hay zonas como
latinoamérica que son de las más
susceptibles al cambio climático ya
estamos viendo los efectos no tenemos
zonas como patemala que perdieron el 80%
de sus cosechas y vamos a ver pues
grandes afectaciones y las metas se
siguen como tú dices postergando y
dejando al futuro cuando necesitaríamos
estar las cumpliendo llega en un
presente
inmediato
bueno pues en el acuerdo climático de
parís había un límite de mantener por
debajo de los dos grados el
calentamiento global que se debe la
disminución a 15 grados que pide la
ciencia actualmente
pues ya sabemos que con decir lo
disminuimos a este 1.5 vamos apenas a
disminuir los peores efectos del cambio
climático
pero si los países continúan solo con
las metas que tienen hasta ahora apenas
vamos a alcanzar esta cifra y en algunos
casos ni siquiera porque países como
china como brasil han estado postergando
y en realidad no cumpliendo con los
acuerdos también en países como méxico
que ya es el treceavo país que más
contamina pues han estado
diluyendo su responsabilidad y esperando
que les den el dinero brasil para lo de
la amazonia para poder cumplir entonces
el calentamiento estos aspectos de
incendios lluvias intensas sequías pues
las vamos a ver que se van a empezar a
reproducir cada vez más y más y más cada
año